jean pas pourquoi il ya une relation
normale et il n'y aurait pas un class
sur cyprien le mongolien moi je le
change et les échevins qui fait que les
enseignants avec tes blagues de mai
tu passais tous quelqu'un mais une vidéo
en ligne
laisse moi deviner
tu cherches seraient pas des
dire cyprien le mongolien ok très bien
rappelle moi ton prénom c'est
tiens
et ben tiens tu dis avoir créé la marque
de vêtements mais collé une feuille sur
un tee shirt n'est pas évident insulter
les gens pour exister je sais c'est
tentant mais fait autre chose de ta vie
tu viens d'avoir 30 ans ça y est ça
revient tat est obèse moqueur
des ensembles ocb mais tu étais déjà
majeur quand on recherche tous base dont
google images on apprend tout sur toile
que sur la trop
j rappeur mais ta carrière décolle pas
d'un pouce la salle que tu montes c'est
sur un bateau mouche
tourner à l'école ces vidéos en sorte à
l'écrit pas elin sans faire une faute
d'orthographe
je veux absolument me rencontrer tu m'as
donné rendez vous sur les champs-elysées
mais ya que les touristes et des pick
pockets tu fais partie desquels j'ai ma
petite idée en tête retourner passer les
dessins animés orthez pékin minus cet
avis est une ligne de but pour toi c'est
le terminus pas la peine de me répondre
tellement bon niveau et mina
chez ma grand-mère pour un niveau
équitable tôt
j'suis balle portugaise faire remarquer
reste du secteur
le magloire du rap francais c
tiens désolé je voulais pas de ça chez
ma mère m'a toujours interdit de taper
sur les handicapés
[Musique]
ah oui au fait que les portables et par
une burqa devant montrer que
généralement on dit podcast